[Music]
how can we make european agriculture
more eco-friendly and guarantee a
healthy profitable production
the answer lies in innovative production
methods and cutting-edge technology here
at the farm of the future researchers
from wageningen university are
developing such solutions for farmers
we head to lelestad where their program
in partnership with the eu-funded
nefertiti project is being tested
[Music]
we need new technology for the new
agriculture so it's a combination with
agroecology and technology
and then the main points in the
agro-ecological approach
are that we have a focus on soil
management
and we have a focus on crop diversity
not only crop diversity and time like
rotation
but also crop diversity in space and
that is mixed cropping strip cropping or
whatever strips of different crops
create many ecosystems that benefit
biodiversity
crop rotation and cover crops improve
the soil a challenge to soil quality is
subsoil being compacted by heavy
machinery one solution is the drilling
of vertical holes to break up compact
layers
loose subsoil is important as it
increases natural drainage of surplus
water robots are key to modern
agriculture they fit nicely into the
methods of sustainable production and
provide useful data
technology plays a big role in
agriculture the machines always got
bigger and bigger
but now with the the robots we see that
we can also make them smaller and it's
better for the soil the heavy machines
do some damage to the soil on the other
hand also sensors
like satellites or drones they give
much more insight in
things in the field in the variability
for the farmer i think that technology
will help him to make
better decisions or better supported
decisions
to make this technology available to all
the european commission's farm to fork
strategy once fast broadband internet to
100 of all rural areas by 2025.
scientific and natural farming are key
to new agricultural methods during the
winter cover crops are used to make the
soil healthy
these plants take up minerals through
their roots forming proteins and organic
nitrogen this chemical is crucial to
life but not if there is too much of it
in the soil due to fertilizers
lab tests are done before sowing and
after harvest to check the balance of
the soil
in the beginning of the season we always
take some soil samples to see how much
nitrogen is still left in the soil after
the winter so we can optimize the
fertilizing so if there's still a lot of
nitrogen in there then we
have to fertilize less nitrogen
researchers at the farm of the future
are also producing renewable energy for
their machines
farm houses and barns are already kitted
out with solar panels that produce
electricity and an upcoming project is
looking to harness the potential of wind
turbines to power a hydrogen fuel
production plant
[Music]
from the electricity we produce hydrogen
gas
we store it here
and we use it for our tractors the first
prototypes are already there for the
small machines we will use electricity
for the engines and the big machines
hydrogen gas so we can be
self-sufficient and neutral in fossil
fuel use
[Music]